Canada is calling Rebecca I Rebecca how
are you I have a peace that passes
understanding how are you days just the
same how can I help
excellent I have a 25% share hold in my
ex-husband's business we tried going for
mediation to divide all of our assets
for the divorce but my ex I was
eventually not willing to negotiate
through mediation so I'm going to need a
lawyer but I refuse to go into debt to
pay for the lawyer my idea is to find a
lawyer who is willing to accept being
paid a percentage of the winnings
instead of me paying them upfront
because the lawyer bills could rack up a
lot faster than I can earn money so I
did some shopping around and I found a
high-protein high octane lawyer who has
a great reputation for not letting her
clients get fleeced and protecting her
clients and this is the only lawyer who
I found that she would consider being
paid from the winnings instead of being
paid upfront and I have appointment with
her on Tuesday so my question is how
would you negotiate a percentage of
winnings to be paid to the lawyer if she
is still willing to accept that form of
payment I think she probably has a
percentage in mind it's usually not a
big negotiation she's gonna be at 30%
something probably somewhere in there
and probably a third and that's a fairly
normal figure sometimes I've seen more
sometimes I've seen less but you know
and you know what it amounts to is is
they they're going to look at it if you
look at it through their eyes for a
second you can pretty quickly figure out
their their analysis number one what is
this deal worth and then my percentage
multiplied by that it means I'm going to
get X right and then if I if I divide my
normal hourly rate into X can I get this
job done within that number of hours so
that I don't end up making a buck an
hour if I'm the lawyer on this isn't me
talking to myself right right does it
change based on how many hours she would
put in because it
to estimate how many hours it would take
no it doesn't change but that's the way
she's estimating it so in other words
let's say that she was going to get 1/3
of $3,000 you're not gonna get much for
a thousand bucks okay I'll take it on
I'll take it on contingency I'll take it
don't take 1/3 and I get 1/3 and then
and she looks at and goes there's gonna
be $3,000 and so she's got to settle
this in three hours right or she's not
gonna make a money right that's the way
she's looking at it and and then you
just do multiples of something like that
and so if she thinks she's gonna have so
many hours in the deal that after she
multiplies her percentage by what the
deal is worth then she's making a dollar
an hour she's not gonna take the gig she
should right sorry what's it worth
potentially a quarter million your part
yeah so about a million dollar and you
think you got a quarter of it yeah okay
yeah well I mean if she makes fifty
sixty grand on it her part yeah I would
do that deal and can she you know is
that can she untangle this barrel of
legal fishhooks and force your husband
ex-husband who's not behaving to behave
during that period of time with
negotiation and or using a judge to beat
the snot out of him probably that's
probably enough money there to make this
work okay excellent so but you know what
I give her 50% of that to do this deal
no no you need to keep shopping you
haven't found your lady if that's the
case if it takes 125 thousand dollars in
legal fees to collect the $250,000 deal
there's something wrong so if she wants
50% then I have to work at the speed of
cash so as fast as I can earn money
that's as fast as she can do her job as
I pay her know if she wants 50% of the
winnings you don't pay her but you can't
hire her because it wouldn't be
reasonable to pay her 125 thousand
dollars don't do this deal okay that's
an unreasonable fee for this deal in my
mind I wouldn't want to give somebody
that much I think I'm gonna keep looking
trying to figure out another
way to do it keep fighting and so forth
and so so he thinks he can just
Stonewall you because he thinks you
don't have the cash to fight him yeah he
offered me $60,000 and yeah he thought
he's being really nice and no he didn't
feel like he was being now he knew what
he was doing okay he's not that dumb you
don't build a business worth a million
bucks if you're that dumb he says all
his money's tied up in building the
hangar and building this and not and the
airplanes that they own and everything
else yeah I understand that but it's
it's you know if you want to buy me out
this is what it's going to take and oh
by the way there was a divorce involved
in case you didn't notice so ya don't
have a choice you're gonna have to
figure this out that means you got to
sell off an airplane or not build a
hangar right now because he's got to buy
out the ex oh darn it that's how this
works
and just keep pushing on it that's how I
do it so hey interesting situation
you're in yeah I think you if the lady
is high-octane high-protein and chomping
at the bit to get after him and you know
she'll take a third I would do it at 50%
I wouldn't do it that's a lot of money
and thirds a lot of money
third 60 grand to her so the other thing
she's got to ascertain really when she's
looking at this as does your husband
have the assets to get and it sounds
like he does ex-husband